peu
[Musique]
cette jeune femme a une jolie ligne elle
veut la garder d'autres femmes elles
souhaiteraient la retrouver qui bien se
pèse bien se connaître mais un maître
aussi est excellent pour contrôler
l'évolution d'une silhouette
car finalement ce qui compte ce n'est
pas tant le poids que le volume et sa
répartition
[Musique]
cette table d'exercice réalisé dans une
grande université américaine à la
demande du président fondateur d'une
méthode que l'on applique dans 78 une
beauté aux états unis et dans une
succursale parisienne permet
l'amaigrissement localiser là où il est
souhaitable elle peut à raison de deux
ou trois séances de 45 minutes par
semaine en un nombre de semaines qui
dépend de l'importance de la
transformation à accomplir diminuer
notablement le tour de taille le tour de
hanches chasser la cellulite qui
alourdit le modeler des cuisses ou des
chevilles redresser un dos qui
s'attriste redonner à une femme une
silhouette jeune et en même temps une
authentique jeunesse
[Musique]
exercice passif qui n'est donc pas
fatiguant qui n'oblige pas à une tenue
spéciale et qui même ne décoiffe pas
[Musique]
e
exercice passif est contrôlée qui
allonge affine tony figure ci améliore
la circulation et qui gagnent bien sûr à
être accompagnée d'un régime riche en
protéines
c'est fini
[Musique]